la france ne peut plus accueillir toute
la misère du monde
par contre ce que j'aime c'est la france
qui partage qui accueillent à bras
ouverts c'est à dire le petit demandé à
nelly arrêté l'enfumage pourquoi vous ne
donnez pas l'exemple prenez-en chez vous
[Musique]
écoutez c'est très simple si une famille
de roms et dans le besoin est la
bienvenue chez moi 2 allée des roses à
marnes-la-coquette et leurs bras ouverts
merci merci accueillerions merci à ces
oiseaux des roms des roms et des roms ah
oui pas décidé mais revenez chez vous
c'est là pour mon seul
non mon palais ça
c'est que je pense bonjour a sauvé trois
bien dormi c'est le chant barrière de
cannes nous c'est pas cette règle son
gros bourgeois riac là on a un port dans
la cuisine on peut pas être plus ouverte
que ça
[Musique]
j'ai moi c'est chez vous ce soir nous
sommes tous des roms nous vouloir
devenir bon sens c'est encore d'y
toucher au statut
[Musique]
d'autres
cochon est presque mais s'intègre vie
peut-être même un peu trop vite
key to fall of health et comité maison
baby créé par baby grand place
[Musique]